this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
Squarespace calm /by graphics to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain Queen Victoria rules I have a
Great Britain for 63 years and she is
still remembered as being one of the
most influential monarchs in history
when it comes to the life of Queen
Victoria biographers are actually very
lucky because she wrote journals and
letters documenting her daily life from
the time she was a teenage girl all the
way through to her death therefore we
know exactly what she was experiencing
in her own words however when she was
close to death she asked her daughter
Beatrice to edit and rewrite many of her
journals and destroy much of the
original text that might offend members
of her family after her death her
children took it upon themselves to burn
certain trunks of her life that they
were embarrassed of because of that we
have the image of her that her children
wanted us to see a woman who is known as
the widow of Windsor and spent her
entire life mourning the death of her
husband but her life it was far more
interesting than she's often given
credit for
[Music]
Victoria's grandfather was George the 30
was the reigning king of England's
during a youth her father was Prince
Edward the Duke of ken's and her mother
Victoria saxe-coburg-saalfeld was born
in Germany before she became the Duchess
of Kent
Prince Edward would have become the next
king but he died when Victoria was very
young leaving her to be the only
legitimate heir to the throne
Victoria grew up knowing that one day
she would become the next Queen of
England at the time women were never
trusted with their own finances to make
matters worse the Duchess of Kent only
spoke German but she was expected to
raise an English queen so the man named
John Conroy was appointed as the
comptroller over the lives of Victoria
and her mother Conroy took his Duty much
further than just being an accountant he
would send opportunist who saw this as a
chance to have a powerful position in
the government and pushed for control
over the way Victoria was raised in a
lot of ways he became almost like a
talent agent for a child star from an
outsider's perspective it would seem
that young Victoria she had the perfect
life she was raised in the beautiful
home of Kensington Palace with toys
clothes servants and vacations brought
but in her journals Victoria often wrote
that she had a very unhappy childhood
together with her mother Connor I
created strict rules known as the
Kensington system the main goal of its
design was to make Victoria weak and
completely incapable of doing anything
on her own she was always in the company
of a chaperone wherever she went instead
of going to school she had a governess
to tutor her and she was never allowed
to play with other children this was an
extremely lonely knife and she
desperately wanted to make friends
Conroy and Victoria's mother they hoped
that if they broke the princess down
enough they could turn her into a puppet
that was easy to control
as a teenager Conroy arranged for a tour
on a train so the Victoria could see
every major city in the UK she was
forced to try and memorize every single
person's name and title at every dinner
party considering these dinner parties
were massive her task it was always
gonna be a failure Conroy would
reprimand her saying that she was too
stupid to be queen needless to say the
demands and the constant onslaught of
insults made a completely miserable in
1835 she was visiting the town of
Ramsgate and she became very ill with
typhoid fever corner
accused of being lazy and being a liar
he said that she was faking her illness
in order to get out of the tour but she
truly was sick and she was lying in bed
in a hotel John Connor I burst into that
hotel room with a piece of paper in
hands he said that she would be a
horrible Queen and demanded that she
sign away her power to him so that he
could be her personal secretary this
would have made him King by proxy
because he would have had absolute power
over all of her affairs she was just 16
years old at the time and she'd spend
her entire life being broken down to
feel completely worthless but she still
had the strength to say no to this when
she was 18 Victoria was awoken in the
middle of the night by her mother and
she learns that her grandfather he was
dead she came downstairs to finds the
Archbishop of Canterbury kneeling in
front of her and just like that she was
the queen of Great Britain
on the day of Queen Victoria's
coronation the prime minister Lord
Melbourne was so moved by the beauty of
the ceremony that he had tears in his
eyes he congratulated her and told her
that she was going to do a wonderful job
he looks at her with fatherly pride
which was something that she had never
experienced in her life
Victoria knew that she could trust him
the Prime Minister became her new father
figure and her very first friend they
would spend a lot of time together doing
jigsaw puzzles and taking long walks she
often wrote that his sense of humor was
her favorite thing about him and that it
often make her laugh however in public
she was forced to put on a serious face
after becoming Queen Victoria moved into
Buckingham Palace and she decided to
never speak to her mother or Lord Connor
I again their plan to control her it
completely backfired
she hated both of them and was glad to
finally have her independence however
that did not stop Lord corner eye from
continuing to try and slither his way
back into power he approached Lord
Melbourne claiming that the Queen
promised him a pension of 3,000 pounds a
year as well as a title some lands and a
seat in court
Melbourne gave in to Conroy's demands
after hearing about his lies Victoria
dismissed Lord Conroy but he continued
to work for the Duchess of Kent while
they plotted their next move when Lord
Melbourne 's time as Prime Minister was
over and he was voted out of office
Victoria she was devastated she wrote
about it in her journals with so much
drama it was almost as if he had died
Robert Peel became the next prime
minister and he treated her like a
stupid girl just like John Connor I hat
he was part of the Tory political party
so he demanded the Victoria dismiss her
ladies-in-waiting because they were
members of the Whig party
Victoria's bed chamber maids they were
her dearest friends so she was outraged
at the suggestion that she should fire
them over politics she flat-out refused
to continue to obey peels orders after
all she was the queen so he didn't
really have any rights to make demands
of her role Hill was so frustrated that
he could not control her that he
actually resigned from being Prime
Minister this incident became known as
the bedchamber crisis
even though Victoria's mother and John
Connor I were no longer on speaking
terms with her they were still trying to
give more power to the German part of
the family they instructed Prince Albert
her first cousin 2/4 with the plot to
get their family more control over the
throne Victoria had only met Albert once
before and by the time they were 20
years old she was shocked at how
handsome he'd grown up to be she ran
home to write in her journal about how
attractive he was and how her heart was
pounding Victoria had no idea that her
mother had plans this clandestine
meeting with Albert's miss they truly
did fall in love with one another
she was head-over-heels in love and as
the Queen she was the one who asked
Albert to marry her in her diary there
are so many intimate details about their
honeymoon it might as well be a romance
novel Victoria became pregnant just a
month after her wedding she was in
constant pain and very hormonal she
struggled a lot with pregnancy and she
was extremely critical of herself
falling into a serious depression
Victoria would write in her diary about
how guilty she felt every time she lost
her temper she would often write that
her husband was perfect and she hated
herself for being anything but sweet and
loving towards him at all times
lil did the Queen know that this was all
part of an extension of conroy in the
Duchess of Kent Kensington plan
Albert's German family instructed him to
keep getting her pregnant so that she
would remain weak and never have time to
truly learn how to rule on her own she
rode that pregnancy made him miserable
but they had a total of nine children
together
unfortunately Victoria did not like her
kids very much motherhood's it was
simply something she was not ready for
and she suffered from a lot of
postpartum depression for all of those
years she stated she had aloneness and a
tendency to cry it is what every lady
suffers with more or less and what I
during my first confinements suffered
dreadfully with all right so Victoria's
life is about to get a whole lot more
tragic and I mean autobiographic svit
20 of tragedy but before we get into
that let me take a moment to tell you
about Squarespace who make these long
videos possible Squarespace it empowers
dreamers makers doers
I really like that ad copy it gives them
the tools to bring their creative ideas
to life Squarespace and get easy - they
have an all-in-one platform so you can
claim the domain build a website and
even sell online there's no
fussing around getting that demean from
one website bringing it to another
working out how to sell something or
whatever it's all neat and tidy on
Squarespace
in fact I got a personal anecdote here
I'm working on a website with them right
now
I had a domain bought it somewhere else
had to transfer it over it was
relatively easy with Squarespace but
just buy your own domain on Squarespace
and trust me that would be easier plus
that website you make not gonna look too
shabby either and by that I mean it's
gonna look amazing they've got
award-winning templates which is a
perfect starting point the immanent
customize it to your heart's content
buses 24/7 customer support chat and
email and they've also got loads of
accessible and not confusing
documentation on how to make your
website
great Plus email marketing so you can
keep in touch with your fans or your
customers look Squarespace they make it
easy get that domain get that site built
get a shop up and running if you want to
do it all with Squarespace head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
Squarespace calm /bi graphics and save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain let's get to that tragedy
shall we
[Music]
in the year 1861 Queen Victoria's mother
died of cancer despite all the drama
that had gone on between the two of them
she regretted not spending more time
with a mother she realized that John
Conroy was the true villain here and she
regretted not taking action to repair
their relationship sooner that same year
though her husband Albert he also died
she was 42 years old and suddenly the
closest people in her life they were
gone after his death she continued to
sleep next to a picture of him and had
the servants lay out his clothes on the
bed every morning even though he
wouldn't be there to get dressed
whenever someone asked her to make a
decision she would accidentally say I'll
have to ask Albert as if she had
forgotten or was in denial about his
death Victoria she already struggles
with mental illness but these deaths
they made it far worse people whispered
that she may have inherited the
Hanoverian madness after all there was
so much inbreeding going on in that part
of a family that it shouldn't be
surprising that all of them were known
for being a bit nuts she dressed in
black at all times and acted completely
melodramatic she wrote letters on paper
with a black border to signify that she
was in mourning instead of staying in
Buckingham Palace she went on long
holidays in Germany in a diary she wrote
that she wished she could have a normal
life and she could live in Germany with
Albert without having to be queen at
this point everyone began to call her
the widow of Windsor for the rest of her
life Victoria wore black every single
day she went on one of the longest
periods of mourning in history people
thought that this was tragically
romantic so they became fascinated with
death suddenly it was fashionable to
enjoy spooky and creepy things and this
inspired a great deal of amazing culture
during the Victorian era now most people
think that this is where historian's
but she remained a very sad and serious
woman for the rest of her days but the
reality is is that she was able to heal
and she learned to love her life once
again
[Music]
after returning to the United Kingdom
Victoria met a Scottish man named John
Brown when she was 45 years old Brown
had been Prince Albert's assistant
whenever he visited Scotland so he was
there two pairs respects instead of
seeing her just as the Queen he could
see that Victoria was in incredibly
lonely women and all she really needed
in her life was a friend the two of them
would get into long conversations where
she poured out all of the feelings that
she had kept secret or just only written
in her Diaries for a very long time
Brown had a lot of sympathy for her and
became devoted to serving her he swore
that he would never leave her side and
take care of her every need
the greatest gift John Brown gave her
was his personality he was loud he was
rude and he was almost always drunk he
would drink whiskey sipping some into
Victoria's drink saying don't stay
thirsty no one had made Victoria laugh
so much in years and she absolutely
loved it that we became best friends and
even possibly lovers if Brown disagreed
with something he did he would yell
woman what are you doing onlookers were
shocked at his level of disrespect but
she actually enjoyed it very much no one
had ever dared to talk to her like that
so treat her like a normal person
her entire life everyone had treated her
like she was weak and stupid but John
Brown he knew how smart and strong she
truly was so he held her to a higher
standard
their friendship it lifted her spirit
out of her depression and she was the
happiest she'd been in a very long time
all a life Victoria was writing in her
journals every single day and she was an
avid reader she made a decision to do
something that no other monic had ever
done before become an author Queen
Victoria published a book called leaves
from the Journal of our lives in the
highlands which was full of excerpts
from her own personal journal about her
friendship with John Brown and how he
changed her life it became a best-seller
and sold over a hundred thousand copies
she even gave a dedication to John
Brown's muscular legs which peaked out
of his kilt her kids they were
embarrassed but then again any kid would
feel embarrassed if their mother wrote
about those things and and published
them after her death Victoria's daughter
Beatrice deleted all mention of John
Brown when she was rewriting Victoria's
journals because their relationship was
considered to be a truly humiliating
stain on the royal family but of course
she could not erase him from history
Queen Victoria had commissioned
statues to be made in John Brown's honor
and plenty of people had witnessed them
together when he was alive Victoria and
John held hands together and hugged one
another in public and of course there
was also the book she published about
their friendship there is also a rumor
that they were secretly lovers Victoria
and made sure they slept in conjoining
bedrooms and their children called him
mummys lover on his deathbed the Queen's
personal chaplain Reverend Norman McLeod
confessed that he married Queen Victoria
and John Brown and secret ceremony years
later we would learn that he gave her
his mother's engagement ring
tragically though she outlived Browne
too even though he was several years
younger than her he died at age 56 so
she lost yet another man in her life
that she truly loved in 1997 a movie
called mrs. Brown was made to dramatize
that love story despite the evidence
there are still historians who refused
to believe the Queen Victoria would
marry a commoner
like John Brown and if she had they
think she would have been brave enough
to let the world know instead of keeping
it a secret
unfortunately we never know all the
details because they've been lost
forever
[Music]
as we mentioned before Queen Victoria
was incapable of running a government on
her own and she was known for being a
bit off her rocker the decisions she
made weren't usually based on her
personal preferences rather than
politics Prime Minister Gladstone he was
very serious and he didn't have any
sense of humor at all
so of course Victoria hated him they
would write nasty letters back and forth
to one another even though they both
lived in Buckingham Palace and could
have easily spoken to one another face
to face the next Prime Minister Disraeli
had a much better sense of humor and
treated her with respect he would
compliment her and treat her like the
rock she was Disraeli lovingly called
her the fairy queen and gave her the
title Empress India Queen Victoria had
never been to India in her entire life
but offered being given the title she
set out to learn as much about the
country as she possibly could she hired
a tutor named Abdul Karim so that she
could learn to speak the Indian language
Hindustani in her notebooks she took
notes every time she asked him how to
say flirtatious or dirty things
Krim became her new favorite servants
and he was given the title of the
Munchie or the teacher Victoria allowed
him to go with her everywhere even when
she was on holiday compared to the loud
John Brown the people in Queen
Victoria's course were actually relieved
that her new favorite servant was at
least soft-spoken and a real gentleman
they saw this as a huge improvement
however Corinne soon began to get
showered with gifts and gained a lot
more privileges plenty of people were
concerned the Victoria was going to be
taken advantage of and that she was
making poor decisions after all being a
good tutor didn't exactly qualify him to
become someone who held a position of
power but the moments anyone questions
anything to do with Corinne she would
accuse them of being racist abdul karim
was always getting sick and it turns out
that he had got gonorrhea but of course
if the Royal physician got frustrated
Victoria would pull the race card once
again
he came with her on vacations in the
Riviera Aran's the newspapers described
him as a servant she wrote a letter to
the newspaper and demanded that they
retract their last story and submit a
correction Abdul Karim was an educated
gentleman and her Indian secretary while
she was incredibly eccentric there is no
doubt that once anyone became Queen
Victoria's friends she was fiercely
loyal and made sure they lived their
best life
at 81 years old Queen Victoria plans for
her death and when she had a hemorrhagic
stroke they knew how to prepare for her
funeral throughout her life Queen
Victoria had been given precious jewels
but they meant nothing to her in those
final days she told her doctors that
what she wanted was a number of
sentimental items with her in a coffin
first was Albert's dressing gown which
she had in their bedroom all of those
years next were the photos of the
children as well as the locks of their
hair that she had collected from their
first haircuts she requested to have a
framed photograph of John Brown in her
hands laying over a heart on her finger
she wore an engagement ring that belongs
to John Brown's mother Queen Victoria's
funeral took place on February 2nd 1901
despite it being in the middle of winter
thousands of people showed up to mourn
and it became one of the largest
funerals in history she never left the
country through war or ever made any
substantial improvements in politics but
people they loved her all the same so
many prime ministers came and went
during Victoria's reign but they have
been all but forgotten you could say
that they were some of the first true
influences everything they did caused a
ripple effect for the rest of society
and Queen Victoria was no exception in
fact her life was so colourful that and
we think of the Victorian era we truly
do get a very vivid image of that time
period in our minds the clothes the
style the attitude of the people they
were just like the Queen serious on the
outside and wild on the inside it's
deliciously romantic and yet very dark
at the same time that time period is
still popular to this day and Queen
Victoria is going to be remembered as
one of the most impactful figures in
history so I really hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do
give us a thumbs up below and do not
forget to subscribe it got brand new
videos just like this several times a
week also fantastic sponsor Squarespace
check them out below and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]